Aven trivets is our next speaker and his
title si
RNA therapeutics for fiber fiber
dysplasia ossificans progressiva our
bodies exist in a perfect state of
balance called homeostasis and the bone
tissue in our skeleton is a really great
example of this you don't see or feel it
but at any moment in time 3 to 5 percent
of our bone mass is being absorbed and
reproduced simultaneously now this is a
delicate balance it can be disrupted by
a rare condition called fibroid
dysplasia ossificans progressiva or FOP
FOP patients have a genetic mutation
that causes the stem cells in their
tissues sorry muscles tendons and
ligaments to start producing bone the
end result is seen at a central figure
here which clearly is a far cry from
what you see in a normal healthy human
skeleton as you would imagine FOP is
severely debilitating most patients are
in a wheelchair by their 20s and are
dead by their 40s at this time there's
no cure for FOP there are no effective
treatment options together with my team
I'm trying to change this but where do
you even start with a disease like this
well what we did was we began with the
stem cells responsible for this bone
formation now the cells of our body are
in many ways like tiny little computers
now all computers have keyboards or
inputs and for ourselves their keyboard
is comprised of what are called cell
receptors because of the FOP mutation
what happens with one of these receptors
is that once it's activated it gets
stuck in this on or activated position
it's a lot like if you press the B
button on your laptop but instead of one
be showing up on your computer screen
you just get this never-ending string of
B's
continuous all the while stimulating
bone formation from these cells so how
do we stop this from happening well my
approach is that we silence the crucial
bone formation genes in these FOP
patients I accomplish this by delivering
SI RNAs or short interfering ribonucleic
acids to the stem cells of these
patients now the S RNAs which are shown
in green up here are structurally very
similar to DNA but they're much smaller
the most important part about them
though is that when delivered to cells
what they
is they silenced active genes that have
matching genetic sequences so in the
context of FOP by silencing the right
genes it doesn't matter that this B
buttons getting stuck because we're
silencing the key genes required for
bone formation now a big challenge with
this approach is the efficient delivery
of Si RNAs to cells because they're very
fragile what I have to do is package
them in polymer carriers before
delivering them to the cells it's a lot
like wrapping up a package before
sending it through the mail system these
polymers what they do is they protect
the S RNAs and help them get to their
final destination now in the way of
results what I've done so far is
established the ability to silence or
prevent these bone formation processes
in laboratory cell cultures what I'm
doing right now is testing them in mice
that have FOP to see if we can make that
translation with some more optimization
fine-tuning and hard work I believe that
we can mature this technology to create
sRNA therapeutics for FOP patients thank
you for your time